Let's go next to our caller from the five
four zero area code.
Who's calling today from five four zero?
Five four zero, please, on mute.
If you have this muted.
There you go.
Yes.
Who's this?
A day that has gone missing from Virginia.
Hey, Mitch.
I was just calling in because I had watched
so many segments on voting for Joe Biden over
Donald Trump and myself, so I'm kind of undecided
at this point.
I am not sure whether or not going to vote
or whether I'm not going to vote for Joe Biden
or whether I'll pull the lever for.
But I did watch some of your segments.
To me, it kind of feels like for you you're
you're pulling the lever against Trump.
And for me, I want to be more convinced by
Biden.
OK, so let me just pause there, because I
want to clarify my position.
Me voting for Joe Biden is not exclusively
me voting against Trump.
There are two people who might be the next
president and I'm choosing the better option.
So, you know, to characterize it as it's only
a vote against Trump or it's a lesser of two
evils.
It's I don't want to put any of that sort
of frosting on the cake, so to speak.
It's here are the two choices.
And it's so abundantly obvious, which is the
better choice that I'm very clear that I'm
going to vote for the better choice.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
I apologize.
That's your position?
Oh, no problem.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I think you might benefit a little
bit from maybe just talking more about what
those things about Biden that you like.
I know.
Like general overview.
And I mean, it's it's very clear that they
have very different positions.
Right.
Maybe just talking about specific policies
might help you.
I don't know if the goal of your segments
is to just stay in position or to convince
others.
No, if this is a very good question.
I'm not trying to convince anyone.
And I'm not certainly I I've not been shaming
people who don't plan to vote for Joe Biden.
What I am if I'm evangelizing for anything,
I'm evangelizing for everybody, to be honest
about why they are taking the action they
plan to take.
So there are some people on the left who are
kind of playing coy where they don't like
Trump, but they really only focus at least
publicly on criticizing Biden and they won't
actually say they'd rather Trump to Biden.
But it's like ultimately that's what it comes
down to.
So if someone says, listen, you know what,
I was a Berney person.
The reason I'm not voting for Joe Biden is
because given these two choices, I actually
believe to hell with it.
Let Trump get another four years.
Now, they might say that because they want
to punish the DNC, they might say it because
maybe they genuinely agree with Trump more
on policy.
But what I don't want is people kind of playing
coy and playing this game where they're like
gay at Trump is bad, but like Joe Biden in
94 didn't take Social Security cuts off the
table.
So.
Okay, but hold on.
He's clearly not running on that now.
That was 26 years ago.
Do you prefer Trump or Biden now?
If people come away and they're like, I prefer
Trump.
I just I'd rather Trump be president for the
next four years.
Beautiful.
We're now clear on where you stand.
But it's the playing coy about Biden being
bad.
But it's like, okay, so would you prefer Trump
to listen?
I'm just pointing out that the DNC screwed
Bernie.
OK.
Do you prefer Trump?
Let's just be honest about why people are
making their voting decisions.
That's all I want.
Vote however you want.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I haven't seen personally, like,
a whole lot of that.
I mean, I guess you're saying like they're
just pivoting.
Right.
They're not saying which they prefer.
They're not being up front.
They're not being upfront sometimes about
who they actually prefer.
And they're not being upfront about their
motives for focusing their criticism on Biden.
And if they were transparent, they're like,
listen, I think Biden as a center left candidate
is going to make us worse off in the long
run, which is why I'd rather it be Trump if
it's not going to be Bernie.
That's a position we can now actually talk
about like adults.
But if we don't really understand what the
goal is of someone just saying, oh, Biden,
this Biden, that will, then we can't even
really talk about it.
OK.
Yeah, yeah, I definitely appreciate your coverage
on all of this.
You've been upfront and honest.
So and definitely everything that's going
on now is definitely weighing heavily on me
with the whole process.
And Trump's reaction to it, it's really weighing
heavily on.
That's interesting.
I felt like someone.
Did you consider yourself a never Biden guy?
No, I don't think I'd ever considered myself
a member, Biden.
OK.
A skeptic will never deliver a person in 2016.
I just felt very strongly and that was a lot
younger at that point.
And newer to politics.
But I just consider I just consider that I
want to vote for someone and not against someone.
And Biden's policies are lackluster to me.
I mean, not so everybody, but to me.
So is there a particular Biden policy that
you really dislike?
Yes.
He's not for Medicare for all.
So that's huge.
Right.
And so is in your paradigm.
So Bernie wants Medicare for all.
Trump wants this crazy thing where 24 million
people will lose coverage.
Biden is into the idea of public option, plus
expanding.
He said he likes the idea of expanding Medicare
to 60 plus plus larger subsidies to people
above and beyond the subsidies we have now.
So it might give health care to, you know,
some tens of millions of additional people.
Does the fact that Biden's position is so
much better than Trump's weigh on you at all,
or does it only matter that Biden's position
is not Bernie's?
No, it matters to me that even though Biden's
position is better than Trumps and is good,
it is undeniably good.
All right.
It is a positive thing to give health care
to more people.
It weighs on me more that his plan leaves
three million more uninsured.
So I feel like we should push for Medicare
for all because.
Wait, hold on.
How does bio saying how does Biden's plan
in the net leave three million more people
uninsured?
You just agreed that that's not the case.
No, no, no.
Not more than current three million people
total will not be covered by Biden's plan.
So.
OK.
I got gotcha.
OK, undisturbed.
He would only insure 10 of those 13.
OK, but so then that's making you think you
might vote for the guy who will take it away
from 24 million more people.
Absolutely.
OK.
Ah, good, good, good, good.
All right, very good, my friend.
I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much.
That is all the time I have for today.
I apologize.
I was not able to get to everybody.
I will take calls again.
Believe you me.